after a long separation atender reunion
at the border fence Eric lives in the
United States his mother in Mexico he
can't visit her she has no visa this is
the only way they can see each other in
person I can I questioned Mexico so
since seven months having seen her today
I got a day to see her I feel really
good I know why don't I want to make a
walk there's a lot of families here in
tewks on nogales they don't cross and
there's only place to see the parents or
the family Sheriff Tony Estrada sees
these types of scenes daily he was born
in Nogales Mexico but grew up on the US
side of the border in Nogales Arizona he
says the two cities sure close ties and
is skeptical of a border wall obviously
a big concrete wall that maybe 20 30
feet high it not something we're really
looking forward to you know it just
continued to two separate as more and
more and besides that it's not the
answer in recent years millions of
dollars have been spent on enhancing
border security but hundreds of
thousands still tried to make the
crossing every year here in Arizona most
travel through deserts and canyons here
at this section of the border everything
seems quiet and peaceful right now the
situation has indeed improve due to the
fence and more Border Patrol's but the
problem is that criminal gangs have
already moved to more remote areas to
smuggle people and drugs into the United
States will president Trump's new border
wall stop them many people here doubt it
breakfast in a migrant shelter on the
other side of the border most of the
people here were just deported from the
US this morning after trying to cross
the border illegally they come from
Mexico Guatemala or Honduras they risk
everything and paid smugglers large sums
of money now they are not sure what will
happen to them from a canal a career i
want to go to the united states because
i have three or four brothers living
there and i'd like to meet them cause a
girl i crossed the border with the
smuggler but he left me behind in the
desert i wandered around until the US
border patrol found and arrested me I
was held for 20 days yeah let go here
mcconnell manana father Sean Carroll
hears these kinds of stories again and
again the Jesuit priest is in charge of
the migrant center day after day he sees
traumatized people Carol says the drug
cartels are firmly in control of the
people smuggling here to change that
they need more than just a border wall
and so there really needs to be a
serious investment in economic
development i would say especially in
southern Mexico and in the northern part
of Central America so that people can
have a dignified life where they live
and they don't feel like they're forced
to migrate to leave their homes to find
a better life for now he and our
volunteers try to help the people here
as best they can with advice medicine
and clothing he knows most will try
again to reach the United States with a
hope of a better life